et tout le monde est beau
on est pas là dedans franchement on est
pas là et puis non rien toi
tu nous fais pas une petite dépression
non non
ça va
je fais pas du fishing pour compliment
non non
j'avoue franchement moi je préfère les
personnes de soi la soixantaine
franchement tu correspond exactement à
mon type
j'aime bien les vieux donc franchement
[Applaudissements]
tu découvres des choses
ma chambre et je suis seul dans la
chambre
alors comment tu fais parce que les cinq
autres chambres du coup
prendre une villa avec 14000 chambres
sera très bien arrêtez de ce bateau
moi je te dis dans ma chambre il y a
là-bas ça peut être Jean-Mi ça peut être
toi dans ma chambre il y a une place à
côté de lui quoi
que vous pourriez dormir avec nous dans
un lit sans que aucun problème vous
ajoutez-leur que vous pourriez dormir
nulle évidemment
[Rires]
comme un frère alors je peux pas cette
année parce que je suis
non non je vais passer je suis cette
année je vais passer je rigole pas
j'irai à Mykonos ah et je l'aurais
jusqu'à l'os